maybe all this violence is looting and
these protests and all these things that
are going down maybe this is destroying
your city maybe that is an
overcorrection but this what happens
when nobody [ __ ] listens and now you
finally get the world's attention yeah
you keep on doing what is gonna keep
that attention mm-hmm like imagine you
broke one store and everybody's like we
hear you now
are you done and they're like okay we're
hurt now it's like I'm gonna keep on
doing this [ __ ] until I'm hurt yeah yeah
what I what I'm concerned about is how
that they're gonna spin this and I
guarantee the media will spin this into
a race war not a war of the people
versus aura T in the way those spirits
are the race war is these militias will
go start to protect the property and
they will create them as one gang and
then they'll create the protesters as
another gang and they'll only highlight
the black and brown people in those
protests they'll leave the white people
out of those protests they'll make it
look way less diverse and they'll have
these [ __ ] gangs gonna look like some
[ __ ] outside of gang out of gangs in New
York or something like that and that's
that's how they're gonna drive the
[ __ ] wedge in man I know it I feel
that's what you think I'm thinking that
they want the writing to continue and
even get worse possibly so then they can
declare martial law what would be the
benefit of martial law Trump can do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do and
probably postpone the election if he
felt like it ooh
postponing the election is interesting
because what I was thinking is he wants
four more years yeah and right now with
Corona and with his tweets it's not
looking good for that's interesting mark
what is where the conspiracy they're
saying what is your theory uh I don't
necessarily have like a nailed down
theory but I've heard people say they
resonate that statement like people even
pointed to on I think yesterday or two
days ago the guard house outside the
White House like they have like a guard
building where like people have to come
in and out they're going to the White
House got burned down I think the whole
thing got like torched whoa and some
people are like wow these protesters
really going crazy you know they're
burning down the guard house and other
people are like how did they get close
enough to burn down the guard house and
then people were drawing connections to
like when the
burned down in Germany before Hitler
like you served power so now like
there's like this weird like power thing
where it's like basically the Reichstag
burned down and Hitler was like oh it's
these uh you know it's these crazy like
friend groups that are trying to destroy
our country and burn down our Capitol so
he's like you need someone's gonna take
over and take control and then he slowly
like gained power that way so you think
Trump could use this as a potential way
of maintaining power outside of the
democratic process Stephanie juice I
don't know if he's got the juice but
Americans are some crazy money he's
talking like it though I don't know what
that's called I can't deal with it then
I'll send the military in there who
can't there has been a historical
precedent some people even say Hitler
burned down the Reichstag himself
probably did like he said like the SS
into burned it down he was like look at
these crazy people burning down the yeah
whole time yeah but like that's not
official record right some people say
it's a false flag some people say it's
not but regardless he got power from do
we feel okay that's that's the most
extreme version of it do we feel like it
is in the best interests of some group I
don't know which [ __ ] group did these
protests continue like I feel like
they're doing everything they can to
drag these protests out I mean there's a
situation where all sides kid benefit
from it okay go so like if trump's able
to enact a martial law thing and he's
able to like have more control over the
government and sort of suppress the
democratic process by enacting like non
like by taking sort of like extra
extraordinary powers and as it's done in
as president then like he would benefit
from the protests and then like the
democrats would benefit from the
protests because it shows that trumps in
complete disarray he can't control
himself and he they know that he's gonna
keep on [ __ ] up so then when it's
election time he's gonna be out like the
anarchists or loving it because they
just like chaos a like chaos like the
grungy white kids that like go to warp
tour and [ __ ] like yeah wanted just
destroy [ __ ] yeah there's an interesting
thing we were having this conversation
about this could let's say the democrats
are the one stretch stretching this out
let's just say hypothetically speaking
right why would they do it and we're
talking about this yesterday like here's
the thing
Trump was on the verge to reaiiy think
on the verge to really get a lot of the
black vote Biden had just [ __ ] up on
The Breakfast Club big time and he
wasn't really remorseful or accountable
for [ __ ] up he was kind of like
blaming Charlemagne like in interviews
he was going he was being a wise guy and
I was returning in kind hmm Charlotte
wasn't really being a wise guy he's
halfway apologized and also tried to put
it on Troutman try to poach it was like
a little both so what I what I was told
is that Trump and his the people that
are ahead of his black initiative we're
putting together an economic empowerment
plan for black people and that was the
time to drop it right literally last
week Democrats are in this position
where black people are not very happy
with Democrats don't feel like Democrats
have done that much to you know further
the progress of black people they have a
huge [ __ ] up from Biden Biden hasn't
said anything eloquent in three years
huge [ __ ] up from Biden Trump has the
opposition has the possibility to jump
in and snag some of that black vote I'm
not saying Democrats started this I'm
not saying they amplified or took
advantage of hypothetically speaking if
they did it would be a brilliant move
because Trump's policy is he has to
appeal to the base on all national
stories it's not a national story if
it's prison perform as long as prison
reform isn't a national story half kim
kardashian comes to the White House free
some black people from jail it's not a
national story it doesn't matter his
base doesn't care but the second summon
becomes a national story he's not the
leader for everyone he's the leader for
his base that's interesting and he's
done it every single time right
charlottesville national story before
right who's there oh there's actually
the people on both sides some people say
that Satan taking out of contact doesn't
really matter whatever it is hordes of
Mexicans coming through in a caravan
they're gonna kill every bubble the
national news story leans into the base
he's not the leader for everybody's the
leader for his base so let's say the
Democrats made this as crazy as possible
let's say they're leaving piles of
bricks just around these protests for no
reason mark was walking
Williamsburg you just saw a pile of
bricks in front of a building who the
[ __ ] is just leaving bricks and fire
bullets let's I was out there with like
a group of kids that were looting cops
are peacefully following them let em
knocking interrupting at all hey I was
in I just lost track of time was
probably with him for like two hours
they were just going around the city
breaking glass knocking over garbage
cans burning some garbage and then they
move on to the next pot and cops just
following them making sure our probably
building didn't get burned but just
London be nothing I mean so so so what's
interesting is let's say the Democrats
strategically made Trump play his card
they go if we make a national news story
out of this especially the looting
Trump's gonna have to appeal to his base
on this how's he gonna appeal to his
base what is his base one oh they won't
word her yeah bring the hammer down
bring the hammer down order bring the
hammer down can be positioned as if he
doesn't have any empathy for George
Floyd in the black plight in America you
can't serve as black people if you're
essentially punishing them for
protesting for their own rights yeah if
you Luton we shoot if you LuAnn we shoe
and he came out they tried to peel
blacks with a rhyme but I don't work all
of a sudden black people gravitate back
to the Democratic Party because they're
like I can't call some thugs I can't I
can't support that dude i'ma have to
ride with these Democrats even though
Biden is incoherent it is it is Kalu
conspiratorial but it's risen
treasonable yeah I think so in
additionally reading through like
there's all these articles specific
specifically in 2020 of why I like the
black vote is so important like all the
stuff was published in like February
March like people are suggesting that's
more important in this election than
ever
why is that because it's more for grabs
more for grabs it's like not as locked
in like the two parties are struggling
to like lock in black and Latino voters
just in general
ever since you just said more for grabs
three times but yeah that's fine yeah
yeah no it's more for grabs like there's
more votes to be had you know people
aren't sure who to vote for
that way every person has a different
version that they can understand
but yeah it's a yeah I think it's just
like less locked in I would honestly I
respect if that's the chest move by a
Democrats that's the first good chest
move Democrats have played in [ __ ]
it's just so hard with Biden yo
I mean his [ __ ] advice to cops did you
see this yesterday I haven't so don't
shoot unarmed people in the heart
shooting them in the leg or arm unarmed
yes oh [ __ ] this guy don't shoot them in
the heart shoot them in the armored leg
if you are the Democrats and you're
doing this brilliant chess move you also
got to get a vice president that can
that you want to take over for this
[ __ ] you get him out of there
somehow it's funny I was telling about
yesterday I'm like this isn't that this
is Biden's time to be out in front of
every camera speaking up and now it's
like matter of fact maybe just need to
shut up was it you we were talking about
the movies talking about this yesterday
we were talking about the the Trump's
power is in his live performances in his
in the rallies in the rallies that you
know we're talking Raul yeah Raul Spring
there's good points out for Raul or
homie from Mexico man and he was like
they'd been quarantined from America
forever but he was like Trump's power on
the campaign trail is the rally yeah and
if you let's say you're the Democrats if
you try to exaggerate the severity of
corona for as long as possible and make
it so people cannot come together he
cannot hold a [ __ ] rally and if he
cannot hold a rally that severely
affects his electability because mark
was saying is yesterday it sounds crazy
to us but [ __ ] go to a trump
rally on some I don't know if I'm for
him or not and they leave they're
convinced
[Applause]
you